hinault favori à 30 ans c'est le retour
du blaireau
le blaireau c'est le surnom de bernard
hinault en 1985 il a déjà quatre
victoires du tour de france à son actif
au programme de la course cette année là
22 étapes sur 4100 km pas de quoi
déstabiliser le coureur breton et son
équipe l'an dernier j'avais une bonne
équipe je tenais japan bonne équipe nous
avons parce que nous sommes allés java
leader pour nous nous sommes ensemble et
nous sommes bon là pour que l'équipe
gagne 28 juin top départ de la grande
boucle à plumelec en bretagne sur les
terres de bernard hinault dès le
prologue de 6,8 km le coureur frappe un
grand coup il remporte le contre la
montre exercice où il excelle en lui
minutes et 57 secondes ce qui est pris
est pris à ne pas apprendre que j'ai
fait le maximum doit s'y reprendre du
temps j'ai pris
puis seconde jeune à l'image
et jacques anquetil maître jacques
apprécié
sur le plan moral ce extraordinaire tout
baigne dans l'huile tout va bien la
condition est là pour tous tout baigne
dans l'huile et inova encore le
démontrer sur la huitième étape du tout
nouveau contre la montre le coureur fait
une démonstration de force avec plus de
deux minutes d'avancé sur ses principaux
rivaux il gagne l'état vous pensez que
le tour se jouer aujourd'hui partie du
tour se joue aujourd'hui
jamais rendu à paris où doit franchement
devant entre vous vous dites je suis
entre maintenant dans la légende des
cytises pourquoi je
fais quelque chose que j'aime humble
combatif talentueux voilà comment le
coureur est qualifié par ses supporters
pour le tour 85 ils sont nombreux à
avoir fait le déplacement qu'elle peut
construire le plus c'est un gagneur avis
partagé par un autre femme très célèbre
est ce que bernard hinault nous ne vous
a pas surpris cette année
un homme de courage comme lui et de
talent
nous a pas nous surprend est toujours
capable de se surpasser bernard hinault
va bel et bien se surpasser à la 14e
étape sa chute est impressionnante mais
il ne veut pas abandonner il franchit la
ligne d'arrivée le visage en sang
je suis juste nez cassé
2pendant de gilly deux points de la tête
il me reste ma de genre mais devra alors
je pense que c'est le plus important
son état d'esprit ne changera pas
jusqu'aux champs-elysées le 21 juillet
bernard hinault remporté le tour de
france pour la cinquième fois égalant le
record de jacques anquetil il est à ce
jour le les français à avoir remporté la
grande boucle
[Musique]